[Music]
on today's show we talked to a wonderful
dad who's struggling with his 22 year
old daughter and her addiction problems
and how far he should go to get her back
we also talked to a mom and a wife whose
husband just filed for divorce she was
just diagnosed with bipolar
she's dealing with the stress and shame
of breaking up her marriage
and we deal with a young husband who
wants to learn how to listen to his wife
better stay tuned
dude what is up happy new year and
welcome to the dr john dolone
show the show is about you your lives
your experiences your challenges your
victories the tragedies
all of it right and i've walked
alongside folks
just like you for almost two decades
right whether your life is cruising and
you're living a full
whole life or your life is on the brink
and it is about to fall off the edge or
you're sitting in the ashes of a
burned-out disaster
you're just sitting in pain and you
don't know what to do next i've been
there
i've seen it and i've committed my life
to helping all of us myself included
re-learn how to be people right how to
live
how to interact with each other how to
stop the anxious depressive
nonsense madness and how to be okay with
who we see in the mirror so no matter
who you are
this show is for you it's for the one
guy out in the lobby it's so good to see
somebody out there
it's for james kelly zack it's for
everybody it's for myself
and i want to start today's show with a
public service announcement
here we go so we are about halfway
through january halfway through january
actually
we got to talk about fireworks here's
the thing they're cool
they're pretty they make me feel good
and patriotic
and all the colors and rattata
to do all of it cool i get it right i
love me some fireworks
and on new year's eve we all have this
collective agreement
that we all are going to stay until
midnight spoiler alert my wife and i
were in bed by like 10 30
and we were like man this is so late and
my kids didn't even know what day it was
we're
when they go to college they're going to
be super shocked that there is a new
year's eve
event but for
the rest of humanity we all stay up
until midnight
shoot everything off and go ah and then
we go to bed
and we've all decided that since we're
all staying up until midnight we're
gonna blast these
these pretend bombs all over the
neighborhoods and out in the woods and
wherever it is that you live
and so cool shoot them off go for it
but it's the middle of january
quit shooting fireworks
for real enough you get your one day
so here's the thing put all of the
fireworks you have left
and my neighbor you know i'm talking to
you put all of them
back in a bag and go to the garage next
to where you put your
ar and your powdered gatorade
and your deer corn and your bulk
packages of slim jims that you buy by
the pallet at sam's because costco's
liberal propaganda right
grab one snap into it and save the rest
of fireworks for july 4th
and here's the thing for those of you
just have to blow something up
we have a half birthday for you it's
july 4th we just blow stuff up that
night too
wait but for real
we give you the one day a year or two
days a year you get to
stop shooting off fireworks man my kids
have got to go to sleep you just keep
blowing it up
and they're and they're pretty they are
and every night we're like oh look
more and now you're blowing black cats
off because that's all you got left and
smoke
stop stop with the fireworks and here's
another quick tip
neighbor while you're at it get your
melted pumpkin off your
porch because halloween's super over two
cool are we all good
it's 20 21 let's go this away stop
shooting off fireworks
this public service announcement's over
so whatever's going on in your life
i'm even sp i'm spitting on my desk
that's gross it's
corona so give me a call at 1-844-693
that's 32.91 that's 1-844-693-3291 or go
to johndaloni.com
show fill out the form and it will go to
kelly and we'll check it out
love to have you on the show i do hope
your new year is going awesome
we're a few weeks in i hope everything's
rocking and rolling and that you are
hanging in there
not only hanging in there you are doing
the things that are going to keep you
well your neighbors well
your spouse your friends your girlfriend
your boyfriend everybody around you well
good for you all right let's go to the
phones let's go to
let's go to my main man gary in fort
worth
texas gary how are we doing man
good dr deloney and thanks for taking my
call you bet thank you so much for
calling in
happy new year so what's going on
brother how can i help
well uh so i have a daughter that's
22 years old she is
homeless she lives in her car
she's addicted to methamphetamine
[Music]
she has two children that were taken
from her
about six or seven months ago recently
learned that
she's been using drugs since she was 14
in 2016 uh her mother
my wife of 26 years uh passed away from
cancer and for the past
or for the last or for the next two
years um
you know i tried you know to do
everything i could to to help
you know my daughter including
you know getting her into counseling
paying for her rent her utilities i
bought her a car
paid her bills um
you know because i wanted her you know
to get on her feet
um you know after two years
nothing worked i i i felt like the the
poster child of uh the enabling parent
so you know the last two years
you know she's really just gone uh
downhill um in the last couple weeks
uh received a phone call from her where
she
sounds like she is ready to accept
responsibility
you know she obviously is struggling
and uh and she's talking about uh
wanting to
to get into rehab and
the first thing that you know came to my
mind
was um
what is the right amount of help you
know what i don't want to do
is get back in this enabling
you know cycle where i am preventing or
keeping her
or giving her an excuse why not to
you know move forward with uh
rehabilitation
um you know so what's the right amount
what's too much
you know i've obviously struggled with
you know
setting proper boundaries you know in
the past
uh and of course telling your nose
difficult for me i
you know i i think i'm i'm i'm a fixer
by nature but i can tell you that
this is beyond my ability you know
to help so dude one
as the father of a daughter i can't
think of
a more gnarly
awful place to be than where you are and
just want to acknowledge straight up
that sucks that's hard
and that's that's that is the depth of
hell for a parent and i hate that for
you
um i also cannot put my head
i've sat with countless people in this
situation i
i can't put my head around somebody i
can't put my head around a situation
where i would have to come home and my
wife has passed away
and so you're dealing with trauma on top
of trauma
and i want to start all this call by
letting you know you've mentioned a
couple of times in this call
about how you're not doing things right
and you've mentioned a couple times in
this call
that um you kind of take an ownership
for your daughter's choices and her
decisions
and i want you to be graceful to gary
okay
yes you're owning a lot of this
and um right wrong or indifferent your
daughter's made some decisions and some
choices
that you've got to let go of for a bit a
season okay
if one day you're you are in a place
where she's well and you're well and
y'all want to go
get a therapist together and go
spelunking i wouldn't recommend that but
you can
at this point i want everything in your
life to be about moving forward
you've done the best you can with the
tools you had because you love your
daughter more than life itself
right is that fair it's very true okay
so the rest of it is cinder blocks that
you are carrying around every day and
all that does is weigh you down at work
that weighs you down in your
relationships and more importantly it
doesn't fully let you connect with your
daughter
okay and so put that stuff down and and
then i want to commend you man most
parents don't ever make it to the point
where you are
which is i've got somebody who's hurting
i'm just going to keep
dumping money and resources and heart
and soul and mind and all this stuff
into a giant black hole
and you've said i can't keep doing that
i'm causing more
harm i'm causing my self-harm and i'm
not doing
the good that i want to be doing what i
do next so dude high five to you man
um it's a hard place to be so tell me
about this phone call you got
she says i'm ready and something in her
voice if if
for those of you listening if you've
ever dealt with somebody who struggles
with methamphetamine
it is a it's just evil in its purest
form
um it takes everything from you it takes
your soul from you it takes all of your
ethics and morals and character just
takes everything you have from you and
um
loving somebody who's caught up in in
meth is
is almost like loving somebody with
alzheimer's they just they're they're a
shell of themselves
and that you want so badly to believe
that they're still there and they're not
they're a ghost
and so gary it matters a lot to me that
you as her dad
got a call and suddenly you feel that
bell rang ringing for the first time in
a long time what was it about that call
that
reconnected you to so
she said that she was stressed out she
said that she knew that she did it to
herself
uh she said that you know she was going
into a
trying to get into a shelter uh at the
time and this was a couple weeks ago
that she
she was saying that you know she had a
flat tire she didn't have any gas she
hadn't
eaten that she's tired um and she
travels from hotel parking lot to hotel
parking lot to
to get their wi-fi so she can
you know communicate on the
uh internet or make phone calls
she said she didn't know how she got
like this she said she was disgusted
with herself
okay and uh and
and i never heard that from her before
it was always the excuses
and everybody else that is the problem
and
and you know the reason she was there
you know she was the victim and um so
this was uh good to hear that
she was indicating that she was ready
you know to take something
ability so when it comes to enabling
here's my thoughts about enabling are
all over the place and they're usually
specific to a particular
individual situation not always we can
draw some some big broad brushes right
but
often it's very human specific it's just
situational right
but most of the time
that boundary-free living comes from
exactly that not having boundaries not
being intentional not setting up
who you want to be who you want your
kids to be what you are going to value
with your money
right what you are going to be willing
to invest in what kind of life you're
going to be willing to invest in
and so all that comes to if
if i don't consider enabling if you
decide i'm
going to pay for rehab if that's where
you're going to go
i would not be in favor of writing a
net amphetamine addict who's lost their
kids
right and that's when you start
realizing okay this is this is over you
some people won't stop coming to
family events and some people will cuss
you out via text message or send
mean phone messages or whatever but it's
when you get into the
to the darkness right when you let your
kids go
when you're living in parking lots right
that's when you know that you
are you're out right and so when
somebody turns around and says
i can't do this i'm i'm at the bottom
and i need help
and then they look to you i'm not going
to ever give that person a penny
a dime i'm not going to write them a
check but if you have the financial
capability and you can help with
rehab and you can pay a rehab facility
direct
i don't see that as a as entitlement
i would also say a person who is a
current meth addict or even
early early stages recovery of any kind
of addiction
they're not in a place to make deals if
that makes sense
and so if you start putting stipulations
on this they're not going to be able to
hear it
they'll say yeah sure great because they
want to get to the next place
they're going to feel hurt and abandoned
and abused if they violate
these agreements that you come up when
they're in the throes of addiction
and then you take your funding away so
i'd be clear and not do any negotiating
i would have a clear strategy on your
part and say here's what i'm willing to
do
um and but it's gonna have to be an
inpatient thing and i want you to know
just as a dad who loves this baby girl
detoxing and getting off meth is brutal
and i would expect some starts and stops
and
i would also expect there to be some
great success on the back end
living into that optimism so what do you
think is too far
when it comes to enabling your daughter
well i i think what is too far is what i
started doing i think what the best
intention was
thinking that you know that i could uh
you know just completely
financially support her and then she
would you know uh
do the right thing which you know um you
know clearly
she didn't um
you know uh so i i i do
uh i i've since remarried and i've had
conversations with
uh my wife about um
rehabilitation and and uh you know so
we're we're certainly open to do
whatever we need to do to be able to
help uh
my daughter um you know my struggle
you know as i said was you know um
what is the right amount you know what
is uh what was too much i mean even when
she called me uh when she was in the
hotel parking lot
uh i did my daughter my oldest daughter
and i
visited with her and we got her a couple
nights in
in a hotel we brought her some food i
fixed her flat tire
i put gas in her car and i gave her a
a food cart to a local restaurant so
she could get something to eat and see
though those things to me
are a dad who loves his daughter right
and i think going into it with the heart
understanding that that is not going to
solve her problem
but you do get that's that's as much for
her as it is for you
right because i ca i don't know that i
could go to bed knowing that my daughter
is sleeping in a hotel parking lot right
and i know it's cool to talk tough about
boundaries and you've got to draw lines
and all that
but i tell you what man if my daughter's
sleeping in a hotel parking lot i'm
gonna go get her
right and that's hard when you're
dealing with coke that's harder to deal
with math that's hard when you're
dealing with
you know when you're just pilled out
it's those things are hard
right and so buying a food card that she
can only use in one place they'll figure
out ways to sell it right we all know
that but
um if that becomes a routine at some
point you've got to draw that line and
they've got to make
adult decisions and it's hard hard hard
i was just going to say that after i did
those things that day i walked away
wondering if if if i made things
worse if i did too much and was she
going to
you know delay sure and and i didn't
even want her to delay a day
right well and that's where um you can
do some work on your end you can go
contact a local rehabilitation place
and you can get the information you do
not want to get information
through your daughter right because it's
going to become at a very
tilted angle and you want to get that
information from
from the the place get the cost get all
that get with your insurance company
and then you and your other daughter go
sit down and have a conversation and say
we want to go today
and we're gonna we're willing to take
you i'm gonna pay for it or i'm gonna
help you pay for it
um but we're gonna go today and that's
the way to set that up and if she
chooses not to that's when you say then
i'm gonna try again in 30 days
and what i don't want anyone to ever do
is give up on their kid but i
there's a difference between supporting
and giving up right
and you're gonna have to get somebody to
walk alongside you because dude brother
you're still carrying some of this
around
is that fair it is okay and
i did have a uh conversation with a
local
rehab today good um uh they asked
me to give my daughter uh their phone
number and name
uh to see if she would call them just
you know to
you know do some screenings so i haven't
i haven't heard back from her so i don't
know if
she's done anything yet my guess is she
won't
right my guess is that um
you're gonna have to go sit pick her up
or meet with her for
um a meal or meet with her and set up an
arrangement
where y'all are going to meet and say
you're going to take her
and again i know that we've got to put
this responsibility on addicts
if you've been if you've worked
alongside addicts for
a long time you'll understand their
their ability to think
rationally is different than ours their
their brain has poison pulsing through
it
and so to expect them i'm just going to
wait until the xyz that
sometimes works and sometimes is an
irrational response
they can't and so showing what
at the root of uh the root of addiction
is a connection issue
they are using drugs to cult to
wallpaper over this lack of connection
and this inability to
to hold somebody tight and to be held
tightly
and so all that to say is gary your
heart's in the right place
i wouldn't wait for her to call i'd set
that up and
some places may not take her because of
that and i would go pick her up and say
today's gonna be the day
and if she gets out of the car then she
gets out of the car and you're gonna
have to have a friend that you can go
sit with and cry with and then you can
give it a shot in 30 days and let her
know i'll be back in 30 days i'm your
dad i'm not going to give up on you
i'm not gonna keep putting gas in your
car um i'm not gonna keep paying for
hotels
i'm not gonna keep giving you money um
that's that is enabling
but when you're ready i'll drive you and
drop you off
and because we've been blessed
financially i will help pay for it
and um that's a gift brother gary so
thank you so much
for um yeah thank you so much
for your heart man and let me know how
that conversation goes and i would love
to know
if she does man i would love to know if
she goes plugs it in that'd be great
all right let's go to heather in austin
texas
let's see heather how we doing i'm doing
all right how are you
i'm good i'm good so what's going on
um i am in the middle
of a divorce after 16 years with two
kids
i woke up in july
and my husband and kids had left and
um i was diagnosed bipolar
after that and i think the
biggest issue i'm having is
how to deal with
the shame and regret that i have
because i'm not getting the opportunity
to fix
what's been broken um
and so how do i sit
and move forward when it's been
something that's been my responsibility
i um you know i know that there are
some people that say that it takes two
in a marriage but there
is when there's a mental illness
involved too
there's a part of me that says you know
this was all my responsibility this was
all my doing
i didn't know what do i do so what did
you do to make him leave
um honestly i was arguing with my
my pre-teen daughter quite a bit okay
and
um in mania i had spoken with somebody
else
over the phone that i had known from my
childhood
so you argued with your daughter and
forget the mania part
okay i want to disassociate here from
the bipolar stuff i just want to talk to
you directly okay
and so take the bipolar glasses off and
just want to hear what are the things
you did
to break up a 16-year marriage okay so
you argued with your pre-teen daughter
yeah all right and that makes you one
nobody does that by the way so that's
all on you
and then what's next did you do i'm
being sarcastic by the way what next
the other thing is you on the phone
talk to somebody i flirted with and that
i flirted with another man yeah
okay so you flirt another man did you go
meet him up in a hotel and hook up with
him
no i did not i never even facetimed with
him
i'm dude i'm so old now i i'm not
laughing at you
i realize there's all these new
technological ways to cheat and they're
all like new
i'm just a loser okay so you argued and
you flirted
what else did you do i
planned um to
have this escape mode in my head of
well it it was back in middle school it
was a group of us we all had this like
10-year plan that if none of us were
happy we'd all run away together type
thing
and sweet yeah and it was
it started out as a joke but it became
the five year plan when he and i got on
the phone and so there was a lot of
fantasy land involved in there
i wasn't
i wasn't doing my wifely job he was i
wasn't giving him the attention he
wasn't giving me the attention and so
therefore i created it
over the phone with somebody else fair
okay
best way i can describe that right so
you had a disconnected relationship
and you began to outsource that
connection other places
yes that's correct and so
i want to put the bipolar aside for a
second okay
and the things that you've told me here
if you were manic often um
that can be exhausting to live with is
that fair
it is exhausting to deal with and live
with i grew up with it my mother
was bipolar okay um and then when it
comes to
the low season give me an example of
what a low period would be like for you
um there'd be sleeping there be i
wouldn't be sleeping at night so i'd be
sleeping in like i think i did my best
sleeping from like 9 to 11
when my girls were in school um and then
you know i would get up and that was
most of my low season but
i had been on medication for anxiety for
15 plus years and what would happen is
every it seemed like every six months i
would go through the
cycle where i'd have um
just the only emotion i could tap into
was anger i
like i didn't when my dad died i didn't
cry when
things happened i didn't cry there
wasn't okay
either okay okay or anger here i just
listen to the picture you're painting me
okay
your dad passes away you grow up in a
house with a bipolar mom
when did your dad die how old were you
uh he died three years ago
okay um cancer it was from day to
diagnosis was 31 days
geez louise yeah yeah it was absolutely
heartbreaking
right
so you grow up in a home that's a mess
that's chaos right
and you're finding defense strategies
and you are finding connection
strategies wherever you can get them
you've been experiencing this low level
burn
sometimes a high loud fire alarm burn of
anxiety for 15 years that tells me
you've been in
a in a semi-connected or unconnected
marriage for
15 years doesn't mean you don't love
this guy doesn't mean he's not great he
may be a great guy
that may mean that you're tough to live
with and your
the strategies you learned growing up
plugged into his strategies that he
learned growing up and y'all just have
had this
anxious connected disconnected dance for
15 years
yeah all that to say is
i don't want you walking around with
this gigantic
cinder block of shame
that you are at fault and more
importantly now you've got something to
point to and blame it on
which is a mental health diagnosis
i want you just to back up and own it
that it takes it as cheesy as it sounds
they're right
it takes two to tango it does
and at some point the disconnection got
to your husband and he walked out the
door
and arguing and flirting
and creating other checkpoints
or not um
that's that's not why you cash in on a
marriage
it's just not okay i didn't think so
either but i just
have there's so much embarrassment that
comes with
what i did because i truly did love my
husband and my children
and then there comes the shame of
knowing that
there is a mental health diagnosis and
i didn't take care of it before and i
didn't know i really truly thought
it was just an anxiety diagnosis and it
what i was seeing people and going to
therapy
i went to outpatient sense i'm on
different medication i'm in therapy
twice a week and trying to do anything
and everything i can
to repair everything but he's just he's
not
willing yeah so if you
are continuing to chase down what was
you're never gonna get well you're never
gonna find wholeness
okay and so this is gonna be another
loss in a line of losses for you
and it's gonna hurt and it sounds like
you haven't fully
put the guard down and grieved it yet is
that fair
i've grieved quite a bit but i am
crying is different than grieving yeah i
think there's still a part of me that
hopes
that you know there will be a fixable
moment after
16 years and the well aren't i worth it
isn't the family worth it type situation
right
and when you start putting external
worths
on your internal wholeness man you're
gonna start chasing all sorts
of all sorts of different behaviors
different people different actions
trying to plug that hole up
okay what you what you're doing right
now working on yourself you've got to do
it for one reason it's because
heather's worth being well that's it
and a well whole heather
who deals with her childhood trauma and
if you grow up in the house of someone
who's truly bipolar
and i say this a lot on the show bipolar
is much much rarer than it's diagnosed
okay um if you grew up in the home of
somebody who's truly bipolar then you
grew up in a
marriage that was challenging right you
grew up with a model of a marriage that
was challenging
it wouldn't surprise me if your dad had
to figure out ways to check in and plug
into other things that would connect him
to
um he was an addict okay there you go
and
um i just had the caller before this
addiction is a connection issue right
and so then you get an addict and a
bipolar person in a room
and then they start a dance you start
you ex absorb that right you grow up
with trauma and you
just do that dance all over again and
your husband participated in that dance
for 16 years
okay here's all i'm telling you i want
you to
exhale and just stop running
okay just put your shoulders down
and you're gonna have to find somebody
if you're going to counseling twice a
week if you're seeing a therapist twice
a week it's a great place to start
but crying is different than grieving
grieving is ownership
it is with a period at the end of it
and then it is letting that part wash
over you
and if you are bipolar if you are being
medicated if you enter the care of a
mental health professional
i recommend you do it with them because
they're going to walk you through it
but i want you to when you go see your
your therapist next
this week when i get off the phone with
you oh great awesome so here's what i
want you to do
i want you to go and say
i am trying to fix my marriage still and
that's a noble
like right thing to do i'm i'm proud of
you for
saying i'm not giving up i'm not giving
up until that core document's
final okay but you can't change his mind
he laughed
and rightly or wrongly um
you are no not rightly or wrongly if
it's because
arguing preteen flirted and you start
checking other places
in in my head that's not a reason to
walk out on a marriage
um my guess is there's probably more to
it than that and if i had him on the
phone he'd probably have
a whole other narrative but mom what i'm
telling you is he contributed fully to
the picture that you're
that you're now staring at okay i want
you to go to your counselor
i want you to tell her that i am ready
to grieve
i've got to just acknowledge what is
happening to me
and i need some help grieving okay
i want you to go get david kessler's
book finding meaning and i want you to
read that book i want you to ask your
therapist to read that book
and i want them to walk you through it
and if you have a good therapist
who is interested in partnering with you
in your mental health journey they will
be excited to get a new
read and to partner with you because
you're taking ownership of your wellness
you're not outsourcing it to somebody
you're not just spending time blaming
i don't know that you're at the blame
and shame part i think you are still
in the grieving part and you've got to
just sit down and exhale
and own this when it comes to bipolar
now you've got your diagnosis
they may be able to give you some
medication they may be able to give you
some strategies that you're going to
have to
work on now and for years but you've got
a lot of trauma healing to do here
and so i hope that your therapist is
well and good and knows what they're
doing
um at the end of the day i want to make
sure you know
that as cliche as it sounds it takes two
people to be in a relationship
and 14 years ago your husband
could have come to you and said we are
two years in
you are anxious all the time i'm not
able to make a safe space for you and i
don't know why and i want us to get
help and i want to start healing now and
you grew up in the home of an
addict and a bipolar mom i want to be a
part of a healing process i want to
learn some new strategies
strategies on how i can create a safe
welcoming vulnerable home for you to be
here in whole and full in
and he didn't do that he left he took
your kids and he left
i want you to be well and i want you to
be whole and here's the other thing you
haven't lost your kids
you got to reach reach out and you got
to show back up to your kids
you don't make promises that you can't
keep you got to continue to take your
medication and continue to do the work
that you know you need to do
so that one day you're not on medication
anymore you've created some boundaries
in your life so when you do have
high seasons and low seasons you've got
governors on your life and that may mean
look
i'm heading into a high season i need to
give my debit card to somebody else
or i'm heading into a low season i'm
going to fill in the blank right
um but don't make bipolar your identity
you're heather from austin freaking
texas you're a mom
you're a good woman you grew up in a
mess and you've got trauma that you've
got to work through
and it's going to take a season but
don't give up on yourself don't just
throw up your hands and say well i got
bipolar that's that
no ma'am you're worth more than that so
heather
i want you to have that conversation
with your therapist tonight i'm
fascinated to know what what they say
i would love to have a client come in
and say
i got this new book i'm ready to get in
the deep end here it's going to start
with me grieving this
loss i want you to tell your husband
i hate that we're breaking this up i
feel like i'm still worth it
if you're going to leave um it breaks my
heart and let there be a period at the
end of that sentence
tell your daughters you're not ever
gonna give up on them you love them
you're always gonna be connected to them
you're always gonna be with them
and then you gotta put the work in every
single day
so heather thank you so much for that
call let's take one more call let's go
to steven in lynchburg
virginia steven what's up my man how we
doing
hey john i'm doing great how are you i'm
doing excellent how can i help man
yeah so i've been i've been listening to
you for a few months now and and i
really appreciate your show and
and i've been hearing you a lot of times
you give husbands the advice
to not necessarily fix the problems not
necessarily try to provide solutions for
your wives when they're
um when they're venting and and talking
about what's
you know going on in their lives um
especially you know in my situation my
wife she is a very stressful
job and so um i i'm just kind of getting
trying to get an idea of like what i can
do more than just saying
you know i'm sorry that sucks because
like a lot of times i'll say it
and then she'll she'll look at me like i
am
there's more than i'm going to say and
you know it's almost like it's
patronizing to her which i don't want to
come off sounding as patronizing that's
right
so you know i just want to kind of get
your thoughts on it well
dude stephen thank you so much i
appreciate your heart and
i'm grateful for guys like you who are
trying to do this right
right just like we just talked about the
last caller um both sides of this
partnership
this marriage have a responsibility to
lean in and to
do their their part carry their water
carry their partner's water
as much as they possibly can so good for
you brother
give me an example of a classic
stephen and wife interaction
that you want to get better at give me
an example sure
yeah so um my wife she works uh
night shift at uh the hospital and so
she'll come home
um what does she do what does she do at
the hospital she's a nurse
um nurse in the emergency department so
i'm just gonna say it for everybody that
sucks
okay so go ahead that's hard it's a hard
job
yeah yeah it is and and so she you know
she'll
you know come home and you know she's
just exhausted obviously because i've
been sleeping the whole night
she hasn't um and so you know i'll be
energized i'll be ready to go
and she'll just say you know all these
things that have that happened and
and you know i'm somebody who's very you
know solution oriented and so
you know i'll provide some advice say
hey maybe you do this
next time or maybe you know maybe this
is what these people are thinking and
and so maybe try to give them the
benefit of the doubt and
i know that's the wrong thing to say
because then she
she uh she um you know you know it kind
of gives me a look like oh you know
i should i should be taking her aside so
stephen what do you do for a living what
do you do for a living
i work at a uh liberty university okay
so you work at a university are you a
professor you just uh
uh student affairs you work in the
institution like administration
in technology okay so
you probably know this but i'm just
saying this for my own benefit
if your wife is working the midnight
shift as a nurse
her job is to keep humans alive right
exactly
to like give them stuff in blood and
needles and hearts and
body parts and stuff right absolutely
which i get queasy about
yes so i will just tell you
just between us dudes um
she's brilliant right oh yeah yeah
absolutely and she suckered you into
marrying her right
yes so she does
not need your advice
absolutely and so we live in a in a
cultural ethos you've heard the thing
like the two fish swimming one way the
two young fish and the old fish swim the
other way and the two young fish ask
like
um the old fish says hey uh
you know how's the water and the young
fish are like what's water you know what
i mean
the water that we breathe the water that
we swim in we don't breathe it we
breathe air
um the water that we swim in here is
that guys have value for two things
their muscles their actions the things
they are doing
and their knowledge that is where guys
get
value from right as dwight from the
office says
guys have strong arms right yeah and
they've also got
knowledge that's it and so you have to
do the hard work of disassociating from
the culture that you live in
which is that your value only comes from
your arms and your head right
you work tech all day people come to you
all day looking for solutions to
problems right
you should be my tech guy i don't know
how to turn email on brother
it's embarrassing right and so guys like
me are coming to you all day hey can you
help fix this can you solve this and
usually you
i'm telling you what you guys set up a
scam uit people got
where you have figured out all you have
to do is like oh my gosh just turn it
off and turn it back on i still don't
freaking know how any of that stuff
works but
kudos to you guys for owning the world
with just control delete and turning off
and turning back on
but here's the thing you've got to walk
away from that cultural nonsense that
you are only worth your advice
what you are worth is your presence
okay and if absolutely most guys do not
and i'm
i'm i'm over gendering this and i'm over
stereotyping this so
go ahead and send me your cards and
letters and i'll forward them on to
james childs here
but so many guys don't even know
what that feels like to be in the
presence of somebody
because they've been trained since they
were four that they are only that their
only value is what they accomplish
and what they can cram in their heads
what knowledge they can impart to other
people
right i watch my 10 year old is always
teaching
people how to do things and it's like
dude i've been here a long time i know
how to do that right you know what i'm
saying
um and so what i want you to practice
is a couple of things one when she
starts talking
tell her i'm lo i'm practicing presents
okay and let her know that you're trying
that's a gift okay let her know that
you're trying that's a secret word
it's called vulnerability let her know
i'm gonna try to be present here when
you're talking
truly listen to you can i give you a
cheesy cheesy thing that people are
going to be rolling their eyes when
they're listening to this
they're going to be walking down the
street listening to this i'm going to
roll their eyes but i've tried it and it
works and i do it regularly you want to
hear it
i learned this from a like a very
um ethereal therapist she was brilliant
and she taught me this
when you keep when you're meeting with a
client was what she was talking about
and you keep finding yourself phasing
out right you find yourself like
getting distracted or you keep having to
lean back in to pay closer attention
she said i want you to pretend there is
a ray of light between your heart and
their heart
just connect to them that way and so in
your it sounds cheesy and oh my gosh i'm
rolling my own eyes saying it
but kelly's in there just going oh geez
louise
no one's getting into this cold black
heart of mine um but
i want you to sit down and i want you
just to pretend there is a light that is
coming from your heart into hers
okay and then i want you to look in
their eyes and just
listen i just had a hard tearful
conversation
yesterday in my home okay and man
it's so frustrating because i thought i
could solve those problems but my wife
wasn't coming to me for that she was
coming something
to me for something that's still still
foreign to me and that was
just me does that make sense yep
okay there is a power in the pause i
learned that when i worked at a law
school there's a power in the pause
just letting that weight of two people
in a room looking at each other just
be and it's something you have to
practice okay
and then i'll tell you what i do in my
house steven and it's worked wonders
after we have that pause after she comes
home and says
hey last night was super ridiculous the
doctor gave all these crazy orders
they've upped our patient load did this
and this and this and i've got to work
overtime tomorrow night
and then your first thought is what it
is you just need to tell
them that they just need to right have
you ever thought about talking to that
doctor and just getting coffee with them
until right so that's where your head's
going is that right
absolutely right yes and so let her
speak
when she starts talking say hey i'm
going to practice being present with you
i just want to listen deeply here
and she'll probably go what happened to
my husband and
michelle's talk and then when she gets
done i want you to be a space
and then i want you to ask this magic
question
are you asking me for my thoughts or my
input here
or can i just be here and listen and let
her tell you
i want you to tell me what you think i
should do next
in be invited into the advice part of
that relationship is that you get what
i'm saying
absolutely i sure do and so when i say
that does that sound nuts
no not at all not at all i i suppose i
you know
whenever when i've said you know the the
you know you kind of
your standard phrase seems to be like
you know man i'm sorry you know that
really sucks and i'll
i'll say that and then she'll kind of
look at me waiting for more and so
i like the idea of saying you know i'm
just gonna sit here and listen and then
and then
if if you want my advice i'd be more
than happy to give it if not then i'll
just shut up and stop talking no no
don't don't do that
what you just did was super dude passive
aggressive
if you want my advice you just have to
ask for it bro like if you want to like
have everything in your life great i've
got it but
if you want to be an idiot don't do that
okay
tell her ask her are you asking me for
my advice in this situation
or do you just want to be heard okay and
preface all of this with a conversation
tonight okay this is your homework
assignment brother
i want you to sit down tonight and say
2021 i want to become a better listener
and so i'm going to have to practice and
so when you come home from work i'm
going to practice not giving you advice
unless you specifically ask me for it
and she will probably hug you and kiss
you harder than you've ever been kissed
in your whole
life but i want you to tell her i think
you're brilliant and i think you are
a gift to the people that you get to
serve and help every night
and probably the last thing on earth you
need is more advice from an i.t dude
if she comes to you with a laptop
problem jump in brother both
feet start control all deleting the crap
out of everything right
like turn it off and turn it on and turn
it back off and turn on dude all those
things that you
uh you guys it's ridiculous what scam
y'all got going but
keep doing all that but start tonight
and say
what i just said i'm gonna say it one
more time for everybody listening
honey it's 20 21 i want to become a
better listener this year
i feel like i'm always trying to give
you advice and i don't really hear you
so from now on i'm going to do my best
to be present and
listen to you and if you want my advice
on something
i want you to ask me for it if i want
you to invite me into
if if you want my like my two cents and
i'm telling you right now steven the
first time this happens
you are gonna have to be biting your lip
you're gonna take a sock and shove it in
your
in your mouth because you're just gonna
be like dude just tell the doctor to
stop right whatever the thing is
you're gonna have to really fight to not
do this
but here's what's gonna happen you're
gonna keep your mouth shut and it's
gonna be so weird you're gonna be
sweating and all weird and looking at
her through the top of your
eyes and it's gonna be awkward and weird
and she's going to think you've lost
your
mind you already work at liberty so
let's be honest but she's going to think
you've really lost your mind
and then there's going to be just a
pause and then you're going to say these
magic words can we just hug
and then you're going to hug and then
nothing and then nothing
then the next time she's going to come
home she's going to say
you know what happened at work today and
you're going to say i'm going to
practice being present you're going to
look at her and she's going to start
talking and you're just going to look at
her
and you're going to pretend that your
hearts are connected i know it sounds
cheesy everybody's go with me on it
you're gonna pretend your hearts are
connected
and then when it's over you're gonna hug
and then one out of five times she's
gonna say what do you think i should
tell that guy and then you're gonna be
like
yes this is my moment just control all
delete or whatever it is you're going to
say stephen right
but then you get the hint you get the
ideas sometimes just saying that sucks
isn't helpful sometimes um just staring
off into space is super not helpful
but it all starts with that original
conversation so stephen again i love
your heart man i love that you're trying
to get this right and connect with
people
men and women you're not worth what's in
your head you're not worth strong arms
although both of those things help
sometimes
there are times when my wife says i just
can't lift that dog food bag john will
you pick it up and i'll say
yeah that's right and i'll pick up the
dog food bag and i will literally feel
good about it that's embarrassing but i
will i'll
be like
and then that's kind of my utility for
the day other than this awesome
hard to grasp hard to measure
our culture gives two craps about it and
that's this thing
that is called presence i just am here
i am with you i'm listening i'm looking
at you
i want you to know that you're known and
that you have value just because
and i hope that by me doing this you're
reciprocating that and we're here
together
and now the tree is getting real deep
roots in that soil
and it's a beautiful awesome messy
messy thing so all right as we wrap up
today's show
this is i'm just going i'm going all in
today
the greatest song of all time no
question here it is
it's from the 1989 end of innocence
record
he said i don't need the eagles a bunch
of birds i'm going
solo right vanilla eyes talked about
going solo
so did the og solo he's not the og i'm
just and now i've kind of lost it here
don henley
in his classic the heart of the matter
and it goes like this i got the call
today i didn't want to hear
but i knew that it would come an old
friend of ours was talking on the phone
she said you found someone
and i thought of all the bad luck and
the struggles we went through and how i
lost me and you lost you
what are these voices outside love's
open door
make us throw off our contentment and
beg for something more
there are times these times are so
uncertain there's a yearning undefined
and people filled with rage we all need
a little tenderness how can love
survive in such a graceless age the
trust and self-assurance that lead to
happiness
they're the very things we kill i guess
pride and competition cannot
fill these empty arms i've been trying
to get down to the heart of the matter
but my will gets weak and my thoughts
seem to scatter
but i think it's about forgiveness
even if you don't love me anymore
forgiveness
even if you don't love me anymore this
is the dr john dolone's show
you